hey youtubers it's Charlie so the CW
just announced the official premiere
date of arrow season 3 in the flash they
basically just announced when everything
in the fall is coming including
supernatural and a lot of the other
shows so I'm gonna do a breakdown of all
the really important dates that you guys
need to remember as well as the rest of
the stuff that's happening this week
because there is VidCon and I'm doing
some special giveaways around comic-con
that I'll talk about hello to all the
new people if you're just finding me for
the first time I do Marvel and DC videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
the next thing that's coming up the next
really big thing is guardians of the
galaxy that's premiering next week so be
sure and go and see it because I'm
actually gonna be doing a bunch of
videos for it so first let's talk about
arrow season 3 in the flash they're
gonna be on different days so I'm super
happy it'll just make it easier for me
to do videos for both of them the flash
is coming first on Tuesday October 7th
at 8 p.m. Eastern Time it's gonna be a
Tuesday show so every week it's gonna
premiere at that time arrow is gonna be
just like in season 2 it'll be starting
on Wednesday October 8th at 8 p.m.
Eastern Time and all the rest of those
episodes will be at the same time there
will be 23 episodes just like last
season they haven't officially picked up
the flash for a full season yet you know
usually it only takes a couple weeks
after a new show starts before they say
yes or no so we'll know whether or not
we're getting a full season of the flash
before November just to give you an idea
of what's going on with the flash and CW
with all the suits and the
businesspeople things are really good of
all the new shows The CW is making this
here like iZombie and Jane the Virgin
the flash is their favorite that's the
one they're holding up as the most
important that just means there's a much
much better chance of them picking it up
for a whole year the way they're airing
the first two episodes of the flash is
kind of weird too so normally on
Wednesday nights the 100 would air right
after arrow but for the first two weeks
of arrow season 3 October 8th and
October 15th respectively
instead of airing the 100 they're gonna
re air the first two episodes of the
flash so basically what's happening is
they're airing those first two episodes
twice during those first two weeks and
then after that it'll just be the
regular schedule it just means they
really want you to watch it and you
should because it's awesome I know I
just did a video about the pilot episode
that leaked that's gonna be the first
episode even though they'll probably
posted online so people can stream it if
you did watch it please use spoiler tags
whenever you're talking about it in the
comments I know a lot of you guys have
also been asking me about Supernatural
season 10 I will be making
videos for Supernatural I know during
season 9 I had to skip a couple weeks
just because I'm still working full time
it's premiering right after that first
episode of the flash on October 7th it's
gonna be every Tuesday night at 9 p.m.
Eastern Time just like it's always been
so if you're an international person the
flash is gonna air on the same channel
that you get arrow on and whatever arrow
premieres that's when the flashes could
have premiere I know the day changes
depending on which country you live in
like I watch arrow on Wednesdays but
people in the UK watch it at a much much
later date so other important dates you
guys need to remember for arrow in the
flash
they're gonna be going to Comic Con and
they'll be doing back-to-back panels so
that's gonna start Thursday July 24th
and ends Sunday July 27th it's just
gonna be like the arrow panel last year
since Comic Con it's a much bigger deal
than most other conventions they'll
probably be screening footage from both
shows if they don't air the flash pilot
during the actual panel then they'll
just aired on one of those other nights
during Comic Con it's about 42 minutes
long and Comic Con panels are usually
only about one hour long so I'll be
making a few Comic Con preview videos
next month that'll explain everything
way better
so other big DC comic shows that you
guys been asking me about Constantine on
NBC and Gotham on Fox yes I will be
making weekly videos for both those
shows Constantine episode one is gonna
air on Friday October 24th at 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time
it's gonna be a Friday show just like
grim Gotham does not have an official
premiere date yet but it's gonna be a
Monday show at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
it's gonna lead into Sleepy Hollow and
they did say that Sleepy Hollow was
coming back September 22nd so maybe
Gotham will start around then so all
those comic book shows are gonna be
airing around the same time and I sold
my soul to get the network's to agree to
air them all on different nights so now
I just have to work on getting that soul
back seriously though this is what it's
gonna look like this fall Mondays will
be Gotham Tuesdays the flash and
supernatural Wednesday's arrow
Thursday's I get a night off I'll still
be posting videos that night but I won't
be doing any Thursday shows Fridays or
Constantine Saturdays or Doctor Who and
Sunday's are the Walking Dead so that
doesn't include like any of the other
bonus videos that I'll be doing like
Game of Thrones on Sundays or anything
else it's just that for a giant chunk of
the fall all those shows will be on at
the same time so that's gonna be a lot
of fun it's gonna be a crazy amount of
work but it will be a lot of fun I will
be doing bonus videos for a lot of this
stuff during the summer so as long as
you guys are current on all the
that I'm posting you're gonna know
what's up and whatever stuff's coming so
the rest of this week is gonna be just a
little bit crazy because I'm going to
VidCon tomorrow I'll be there through
Saturday and Legend of Korra book 3 is
premiering the first three episodes on
Friday starting at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
that's on Nickelodeon in the United
States they'll post the episodes the
next day on their website so if you're
an international person you should be
able to watch them by Saturday or Sunday
depending on which time zone you live in
and don't worry I'm gonna be posting a
bonus core video Friday morning that's
gonna explain all that stuff again to
anybody who will also be at VidCon this
weekend and want to meet me in person or
say hi please let me know either on this
video or on my Facebook page or on
Twitter don't worry there's links for
all that in the description if enough of
you guys are gonna be there then I will
arrange for like a special Meetup
but if only a couple people there then
I'll just arrange for us to high-five
each other as we pass by in the hallway
I will be posting a personal Q&A this
weekend so if you ever wanted to ask me
questions about me you can do so either
on this video or on Facebook Twitter any
of the other videos I do this week that
videos probably in a post on Saturday or
Sunday so here's the big update on some
of the giveaways that are coming
including the ones that are going on
right now just in case you don't know
you should know about the weekly Game of
Thrones giveaway that I'm doing this
summer I'm just giving away one Song of
Ice and Fire book to a random subscriber
in the comments on my Game of Thrones
bonus videos the first winner will be
announced this Sunday whenever I post my
next game of Thrones video so my Legend
of Korra giveaway is gonna be the same
deal except it's gonna be an Amazon card
and I'm just doing one giveaway for each
episode this season the special
giveaways aside from those are Comic Con
and I'll be doing a separate giveaway
when all the comic book shows come back
in the fall so here's the details on the
Comic Con giveaway and don't worry I'm
gonna post a bunch more Comic Con videos
that'll explain this a little bit better
but for every show that I make videos
for that's at Comic Con I'm just gonna
be giving away one prize it'll be
something like central to the theme of
that show so they'll be like a Doctor
Who prize walking to Game of Thrones
arrow you know you get the idea each of
the prizes will be worth at least $20 so
if I do like 10 shows and they're all at
Comic Con
it means I'm giving away 10 prizes so
all the prizes are going to be different
but they'll all be the same value then
when everything gets ready to premiere
in the fall I'm gonna do the exact same
thing just one prize for each show and
as always all the giveaways are open to
international people whenever we get
closer to those give
I'll remind everyone again so don't
worry right now click here to learn all
about the leaked episode of the flash
and click here to learn all about the
Batman villains that are coming to the
Gotham TV show this fall thank you so
much for watching I'll see all you guys
at VidCon high fives